une fois par an la loire entre en bois
et tours accueille une compétition
internationale de nage avec palme avec
son parcours de 23 km c'est la plus
longue course de fond de la fédération
je les fais l'année dernière donc je les
gagne et ça va donner envie de revenir
mais aujourd'hui c'était plus dur et
puis avait peut-être plus de deux
costauds donc mais c'est dur c'est dur
mais c'est pour ça qu'on vient quand
même une course sportive mais aussi
mythique qui permet de nager dans le
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
au total sportifs de haut niveau et
amoureux du fleuve étaient 105 à
s'élancer dans le fleuve royal lot 12
degrés 2h30 à 3h 30 jusqu'à 4 heures de
navigation
c'est à dire qu'il faut être préparé
après ce qui est beau c'est de savoir
lire une rivière on n'est pas en canal
on n'est pas sur un lac
c'est à dire que là il ya une véritable
lecture de la rivière donc lecture de la
nature c'est dire la loire selon la
couleur verte plus ou moins foncée vous
savez s'il ya du fond pas de fond les
cours en bas il faut savoir les les
choisit reprendre le mot si vous voulez
pas vous en sable et donc ça c'est beau
ça c'est beau parce que ça remet l'homme
dans la nature
[Musique]
interrompu en 2007 la descente en bois
ce tour en est à sa deuxième édition et
confirme ainsi son renouveau